welcome back everyone to this special
edition of hannity now a very big win
for religious liberty this week
after the supreme court ruled against
new york governor andrew cuomo
and his draconian attendance
restrictions on houses of worship
and a 5-4 decision which uh included
newly appointed justice amy coney
barrett
in the majority the court found that the
governor's actions trampled on the first
amendment's guarantee
of the free exercise of religion and in
his uh concurring opinion
justice gorsuch exposed cuomo's moral
hypocrisy writing
it is time past time to make plain that
while the pandemic poses many grave
challenges
there is no world in which the
constitution tolerates color-coded
executive edicts
that reopen liquor stores and bike shops
but shutter churches
synagogues and mosques bravo sir
but rather than take responsibility for
his unconstitutional action
governor cuomo lashed out at the court
telling reporters
the supreme court made a ruling it's
more illustrative of the supreme court
than anything else
and meanwhile religious leaders praised
the ruling reverend franklin graham
thanked the justices
for standing up for religious liberty
and cardinal dolan tweeted our churches
are essential but how did the far left
react to the supreme court upholding the
fundamental first amendment rights
by spewing more rage hate and hysteria
at the five justice justices and
specifically
justice barrett for example failed obama
adviser ben rhodes called the decision
illegitimate and new york times
columnist paul krugman
claimed the decision would get people
killed
and other unhinged leftists expressed
their ire by tweeting out
amy covid barrett ha ha